اكثر من 100 نائبا الماني اصبح رعاه
لسجناء سياسيين في ايران في الايام
الماضيه التحرك الذي بدا صغيرا مع عدد من
النواب من الحزب الاشتراك الحكم توسع
كثيرا في الايام الماضيه يقولون لنا كافي
منصوري احد هؤلاء النواب الذين بداوا
التحرك منصوري المولود في المانيا لوالدين
ايرانيين يشرحون الرعايه السياسيه تعني
الاهتمام بقضيه السجناء والتعامل مع
المحاكمات الصواريه التي يتعرضون لها في
ايران
لنظام الايراني لان ما يحصل حاليا هناك من
محاكمات سوريه لا علاقه له باي شيء يتعلق
بحكم القانون وقد لاحظنا في الايام
الماضيه ان الضغوط على ايران تحدث فرقا
وهي غالبا تساعد منصوري واسنانه واربعون
نائبا
وقعوا وثيقه تطالب الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر
مع النظام الايراني وحظر للحراس الثوري دي
تقول الحكومه انه قرار يتخذ داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي
هو الاهم والاكثر رمزيه ولكن يعتقد انه
يجب اتباعه بعقوبات اضافيه ضد منهم في
السلطه في ايران واعتقد ان الخطوه التاليه
يجب ان تستهدف النواب الايرانيين المئتين
227 ومن له يدوم في اعدام المتظاهرين من
قضاه ومددعين وغيرهم وهذا يبعث برساله
واضحه اننا لن نتغاضى عن جرائم ضد حقوق
الانسان
تقويه موقف وزيره الخارجيه التي تتحدثون
بدايه التظاهرات عن مساء الاوروبيه لاضافه
الحارس السوري للائحه الارهاب هذا التحرك
الذي يشهده البرلمان الالماني وصل صده الى
برلمانات اوروبيه اخرى في فرنسا وبريطانيا
والسويد وغيرها من الدول التي يتواصلوا
نوابها مع نواب الالمان لمعرفه كيفيه
سجناء في ايران راغده بنام العربيه بلين